good morning everyone and welcome to the
waset meeting for
October do I have any apologies I have
one apology that has been received um
from Ian Pinger
and also there is an apology um from
nille um last name's Von blank Steve
councilor Philips Phillips pH thank you
uh can I have a move that those
apologies be accepted
please um Rob thank you and um Peter
sorry
bar all those in favor say I I against
carry
are there any conflicts or other
interests that people have at this
meeting
please shaking of heads appears not
thank you item one is the uh minutes of
the previous meeting are there any
errors or omissions that people uh have
identified with the those
minutes there appear to be none can I
have a move in a second or that the
minutes are correct and can be adopted
thank
you uh Barry and Rob there is just one
alteration on that confirmation of
minutes on the last one has got me down
a school district
C and that's on page page
two page two which is five of the agenda
confirmation minutes yes
correct so that should read
IC yeah let's see anything that's
wrong so we had a move and a second of
that they be accepted all those in favor
say I I against carried um are there any
items that um arise from that before we
head to the main
agenda
just um one quick question I guess to
staff uh the item four which was the
coai where um we agreed to uh endorse
The
Proposal um is is there any update on
that because my expectation is that we I
would write a letter to the ministry
giving support to
that
that right thank
you right the second item on the agenda
is is a uh presentation from Plato
creative um do the staff want to just
give a a brief intro as we click into
that good
morning
and we can bring the Plato up on the
screen now
thanks oh why seem to turn
on good morning um so we had engaged
Plato start of this year to create um
content for us education material
promotional material everything so we
are already getting um information from
MF but that needed to be um put into a
language that our community would better
identify with and um it's appeasing to
the community and it's um
straightforward message to the community
so Plato has been doing some wonderful
work um to um deliver that message to
the community put it in the right frame
put it in the right sense make it simple
easy to understand so Plato has been
working in the background quite a bit
and we've got them um here to Pres sent
to you some um really good campaign um
ideas and uh
mascot that the community would better
engage with thank you for that just to
support uh Annie's comms and through
yourself Mr chair uh Plato who are our
external um stakeholder of Supply that
we're tasked with uh obviously breaking
down the story we're trying to outline
to the community and to our stakeholders
around some of the complexity you know
we work in quite a complex environment
in the waste field trying to compress
that complexity and keeping short sharp
Punchy coms to the public keeping them
engaged across the board um across a
number of different disciplines in the
waste field so uh playar done some great
work um looking forward to uh yeah
showing you the where we've landed as
far as a presentation goes and what the
plan is right thank you so welcome to
the um group from Plato creative uh
we're looking forward to the
presentation you're giving this morning
and and um over over to you
guys thank you very much thank you I
will just uh share my screen
just we go uh thank you so much for the
introduction um as was mentioned we are
PL creative uh we are located in Christ
Church and uh we are very privileged to
uh be putting um our thoughts together
for this new uh wasn Campaign which
we're really excited about So today
we're not going to take too much of your
time up but we're just going to take you
through uh kind of the journey that
we've been on to date um and some
exciting Concepts uh that we think is
really going to resonate with the local
community so I'll hand over to H Fiona
and she is going to start with the our
presentation
hi team so on that first page there's a
lot of text there and I'm sure you're
all familiar with the vision for 2050
this has come down from um the ministry
and then uh in the middle there we have
waste Nets Vision that is by 2035 all
our residents and businesses in the
Southland region will have a better
understanding of waste of minimization
and they'll be taking actions towards
that and our aim of course is to promote
waste minimization and resource recovery
through these tools through education
through communication that's why here
today to talk about all of
this uh there was a bit of research done
in the background this has all been a
bridged for today's presentation but
some of the main challenges are as as
has already been stated that um
sometimes these messages could be quite
complicated and we really want to make
it not only easy for people to
understand but easy for them to take
action um there's a bit of apathy around
making change that's just humans and
general uh there was a question mark
over the at the moment Wast net has the
love Southland logo and tagline there
was a question mark over whether that
should uh continue or whether we need
something
new um there was some research done
sorry we dipped into a bit of press
around Wast net and um there was a bit
of bad grp unfortunately but I guess
that presents an opportunity for us to
come forward with um a different message
for people going forward with this new
strategy we want to make sure that
whatever we put out there is really
engaging for people uh and that it can
be communicated over a long period of
time and that one is really key to the
um solution that we've come up with
today so the vision and Mission as we
just said before they're not very public
friendly we've got big old words in
there like waste minimization which we
all understand um circular economy we
all understand that but not everyone out
in the public is going to so we want to
make it much easier for them and what
we're proposing is for introduce what's
called a communications platform and if
you think that word platform that means
a base a foundation something that is
the common thread that runs through
everything that we can build off and
there's a couple of ways in on this we
thought you can either summarize that
big um mission and vision into just a
little
statement for the public so they
understand roughly you know or sorry so
they understand the big picture or we
can give them a bit of a um a tagline or
a catch all instruction that they link
with the vision and Mission and the
other thing that's really great about a
communications platform and I'll show
you an example of one in a second is
that it can act as a an intermediary
between Wast net and the public and the
communications so people uh the message
is being delivered on behalf of wasn but
by a different brand so we'll show you
what that looks like as an
example our Communications
platforma have at the moment their
platform is road to zero and that's
their mission to have zero Road deaths
by a certain time and then you can see
how the communication gets built off
that and they've got a couple of ads out
there I don't know if you've seen the
one where everyone uh the car has a near
myth and everyone piles out of the car
it takes everyone to get to know one and
there's another one it's time we stop
paying the road toll and as you can see
there that little o and the has got the
Crosser which is their link back to the
platform and all those ideas link off
this vision of road to zero so what
they've done is they've really
simplified what it is they're looking
for and made it easy for everyone to
understand and this has been going for a
little while and the really good thing
about a communications platform is that
because it's this simple idea that um
everything is founded on you can keep
the message consistent for a long period
of time so that we could can drive real
change another really good example if
you've ever seen the all right campaign
so this is actually delivered now by the
Ministry of Health and its messages
about well-being but you never seen
Ministry of Health logo on there you see
the all right brand and everything comes
out from this intermediary brand called
all right and what they've done and this
is why it's a really good example of the
platform as well is that they've used
the five ways of well-being if framework
for delivering well-being messages and
it's a really good integration of to or
mal as well uh and so the platform could
be strengthened with bicultural
consideration to come down the
track so what would our platform
be rethink rubbish so why we've come up
with this term it's active which is
really great it's an example like we
said before of giving the audience an
instruction of what we would need them
to do we need them to rethink rubbish um
one of the things that's been considered
here is that there's a difference
between the word waste and the word
rubbish and the reason we've gone for
rubbish here is not only does it have
the Double R U people love a pattern and
they respond really well to things like
this but rethink here uh it means to
consider or assess again something uh in
order to change it and that really is
what we need people to do here is to
look at waste and have another thing can
can it be reduced can it be reused or
repurposed that resent there's a nice
little line there that ties in with all
of those uh and as a lock up there and
what we mean by lockup is it's sort of
like a a bit of a logo if you
will it's kind of representing the
flipping of perspectives because as well
as New U as well as New Zealand's Target
of becoming a circular economy it's got
that Circle in there but you kind of
look at it and you think you're looking
at it from the outside in and then it
kind of changes actually it looks like
we're looking from the outside so
symbolic of changing the way people are
looking at things as
well so reink rubbish well we're not
actually the only ones talking like this
and when we dug into it we found that
there was a few um local authorities
around the country who are using
including I think War already is using
these words rethink or rethinking waste
or rethinking rubbish and we thought
actually that probably a really good
sign because what it shows is that the
message is is likely correct because
everyone else is saying it in a similar
way uh because we're not a private
Enterprise and a competitive market uh
we it means that nobody owns the
statement as such so we can also use it
there's unlikely to cause confusion
because our communication probably
regionalized so it's not like somebody
in the North island is going to see this
and get confused that it's a message for
them but essentially what's really
awesome is that everyone the whole point
of the waste strategy is standardization
that's the task at hand that we're
trying to get um all all the people of
New Zealand on board with and so we
think that actually that is what gives
us a really big tip is that we're all
working towards the same thing so re
think rubish as the platform
communication and then as was sort of um
mentioned oh sorry just really quickly
refin rubbish would replace love
Southland and I think love Southland had
it time but now we've got a new Mission
and it needs this new instruction for
people so as was sort of preface as well
re the rubbish the platform but actually
we think that we could have some wins by
introducing a mascot and there's a
little bit of an article there which
proves that actually mascots in
particular when it it comes to public
service announcements or messages like
that um mascots can be really effective
in getting people on board particularly
around um environmental issues there's
some examples there from America with
woodsy the Al and Smoky the beer who um
had a real impact on people's
understanding of environmental
messages the use of distinctive assets
like a mascot have the ability to really
increase the likelihood of the
communication being classified as as
high on brand attention so what we're
basically saying here is that if you
keep it
consistent it builds recognition with
people and it's more likely to drive
change and we thought when we're coming
out with a mascot here's an opportunity
to walk the talk we're telling people
that we need for them to rethink rubbish
uh so let's do the same so rather than
create a new mascot we thought what if
we actually Liv this Miss Mission and we
built the mascot from existing parts so
what can we reuse or repurpose to put
this person together we sort of thought
maybe it's an ice cream stick or pipe
cleaners or rolled up
newspaper uh tin cans tennis balls you
never know what actually could be put
together to make a little um character
and there's some examples there in the
merge but here we go here he is here's
our Guy bits McGee the future of how we
deal with waste is changing for the
whole of New Zealand so we're rethinking
rubbish here in Southland too hi I'm bit
mgee and I'm here to help us all find
ways to reduce how much rubbish we
create and how we deal with what we do
repair reuse repurpose recycle recover
get ready to discover the many ways we
can rethink r and work towards our lower
waste circular economy by
2050 yeah we had to um we do have an
approach of engaging the community to
create um our mascot and and how we
launched it um can you speak
up sorry thank
you McGee here is is purely conceptual
at this point and it's not that this is
the actual mascot or character that will
um it will be going forward with but you
know I guess this is a good example of
um how how this mascot looks feels is
put together like kind of as crazy and
as wacky as as possible you know but
obviously we'd love uh the community's
input in terms of creating this
character so they feel that they've had
an involvement of um of you know
creating something that represents
themselves we've also been talking um
with you know there's been a couple of
groups uh that represented this to up to
this point and one of the things that's
come up that we think is really cool is
I we'd love to incorporate something
that's really super saing into this guy
and there's been suggestions of maybe
he's got a sweed heart or maybe he's got
power shell ears something like that
that's um you know really connects with
uh with people
locally so we just started to um now
that we've got a bit of a concept you we
want to show you I guess what might it
look like out in the world um with that
recent rubish logo with our mascot that
there so here's just some examples of
Street
posters we saw actually why don't we hit
people at the source of where we need
them to be rethinking rubbish and one of
the first um messages to come out is
going to be around Recycling and
curbside standardization and those sorts
of things so we thought potentially bits
he um could be really awesome as a
sticker on
thins you could have some real fun with
him with the messages you know the we
need to get people to learn um that
there's certain things you need to do
with your recycling so here's an example
of a recycling message where you can see
bits really engaging and I guess what's
really nice is um it's fun and it's
really when it's fun for people they're
much more likely to engage with it and
get on board and enact change rather
than because it's something that they
are joining into rather than being told
what to do
we also thought you can get really um
targeted with the messages and whil we
think B will really appeal to uh younger
people we also think that he's got
enough charm to appeal to the uh to BR
our audience as well and we also thought
it could be that it's maybe the message
that you have bit deliver so here's just
an example I guess of um what do adults
care about they care about the rapes of
the paying when it comes to our you know
waste strategy so it's just an example
of a message of bits talking to adults
there so ultimately we feel like this
idea is going to give us the best
possible chance of achieving those lofty
goals set out by the ministry plan for
2050 this is definitely going to capture
the Public's attention and therefore
much more likely that our messages will
not only be remembered but that people
enjoy receiving them we need this to
last so we think this has got longevity
because it's um a character your
character can um I guess they are the
constant and you can change the message
they deliver really good examples of
some characters who had longevity um if
you think about Stickman for pack and
save he's been around for quite some
time now and not a lot has changed um I
guess about Stickman himself but he has
been able to deliver whatever message T
needed him to
deliver so bits and reink brother should
be our voice be the voice of our
messages uh and because he's really
engaging and fun to deal with and he
would stand there in front of the Wast
brand any um issues that the public
might have or any past um thoughts of
who they think Wast net are or what
waset do we get to nullify that we can
connect with a really broad range of tar
groups across the region um from schools
to businesses to
Residents we just think it's going to be
lovely to inject a bit of joy into a
somewhat utilitarian topic because we
are talking about waste minimalization
and like we said people are going to
need to act so we want to make it
something that they want to do rather
than they being told to do we think
there's an opportunity here to generate
Community engagement and involve it uh
and even better put the Southland
recycling initiatives on on the map in a
positive
way so we've just got a bit of a draft
timeline here that we're working through
with the waset team at the moment so uh
we are looking to launch uh rethink
rubbish basically as soon as possible
but likely more uh within November and
then move through with our two key uh
pieces of communication the first one
being curbside standardization and then
again the glass implementation so uh
bits and the rethink rubbish uh campaign
it will run across um yeah the the
following months so we're looking
forward to yeah getting it live for you
all to see so some of those next steps
that we're working through at the moment
are we're working on a channel plan and
some of that launch activity uh so some
of those channels that you might start
to see bits and the rethink Rel Contex
across uh print media uh social media
outdoor uh really as be said getting
into the community schools and the
businesses to get the this uh these
messages across and then we've also got
some uh clever ways we think we can
bring this to life through radio as well
um and then also we're working with the
team on creating a tool kit of assets
that will be uh available for all of the
councils which will have Flyers fin
stickers uh direct mailers social
templates uh that align with the
campaign concept so that you can uh take
those key messages that are coming from
the ministry put them together with our
our concept and talk it and get them out
uh into the
community that is up today so I hope
that that gave you a really good uh idea
of uh the concept that we're going to
bring to life and um yeah we're really
excited to to get cracking on it
further thank you for that it shows a
lot of work has gone into it and and
there's some exciting opportunities
arising from it is there any feedback
comments from Members
please
Christine um thank you I like the um
concept it's nice and simple and
engaging and um I'm interested to see
that you have um included the radio or
the media in there because I see real
potential for that to be um putting our
audience to date in a different
way um so I'd be interested just to hear
a little bit more about what that's
going to like in the near future
particularly if you're starting to do it
in the in the next month or
so so I guess what you're flagging is
for our next meeting if we can just have
an update as to progress yes yes yeah
absolutely we're working through all of
that at the moment and how um bits will
start to come to life through radio
we've had a few initial thoughts around
that
um maybe even a role of the r might come
through through his character um but
yeah we've got some some clever ways
that it all come to life and we'll be
sharing with those and the come I was
also interested in that that your
research is showing that Southland is
the most lited region in the in the in
New Zealand so if you're able to break
that research down into which parts of
Southland I'll be interested in that too
because I think as a district council we
have a part to play and um addressing
that yes sure think with push that out
for you guys I'm not sure if it went
into this specific minua of um by region
but certainly we can have a look for you
that's something that the team are able
to provide the background to I think it
it was it's probably research that I
think was limited and at a point in in
time but we can give that breakdown of
essentially where they did surveys right
around New Zealand of different areas
and what they came up with those figures
um we can collect that info and provide
it that's good and the type of litter as
well I can certainly see it on the sides
of the roads and that's an increasing
issue I think um that being said I think
that we're not the only ones who are
having that as an increasing issue at
the moment I think probably a sign of
the financial
times thank you any any other feedback
comments Barry yeah I'm that you
mentioned the radio there I'm quite
impressed with the way it comes across
the radios I've heard it quite often
lately and it's seems to work really
good that radio thing I've heard many
comments about it I was in the garden
yesterday when one of the ads was
playing yeah and and it came across very
clear yeah it does I actually stopped to
listen which you don't normally
do any other
feedback Rob just just a comment on the
on the campaign I really like it and I
think yeah it's getting in the right
direction yeah just a positive comment
I'm quite impressed um a a question in
terms of the character himself um most
of the items that are showing on it are
amorphus yet we have um Marite showing
up um is is there any reason for that
and are we actually giving some free
advertising or whatever you're that was
it's just conceptual and um that's where
we would maybe look to find like maybe
maybe there's a swed or a power shell or
something local that Finds Its place on
bits yeah we did um
I see as part of the concept that was
his peewi heart um but yeah that is uh
yeah work in progress and definitely
something that we would look to have
something else in there yeah no we don't
want to go free as
M be white fell
um bar I noticed there's no no mention
to batteries here Li here in B if anyone
watched uh Sunday last night was a
perfect example of what what happens
with lithium batteries and we've got a
real problem down near landfill if one
of the compactors runs over
one there's a real problem after that
because it goes on fire yeah and there
have been several instances of fires
there from from batteries yeah and it's
an evolving issue nationally as well as
here
yeah there something to think about so
there's this presentation kind of morphs
into the item that we've got on their
agenda um which which is um item three
which is on page 11 which is really just
giving a summary of of what we've got in
including the the graphics that that
were um there um while we've got um the
guys from Plato creative online are
there any questions in terms of uh the
item that's in the
agenda I think the staff want to make a
a a comment in relation to
that I will just add to uh some of the
questions that wagger brought up through
yourself Mr chair um but mge's voice is
very very distinctive um we the pl team
have been working around in that
creativity space to see what that may
sound like bits may sound like and some
of the examples that they provided
through to Annie and Jackie have been
absolutely superb so we'll really
resonate on the radio we'll be quite
catchy on social channels and um yeah
sort of reinforce I guess the P we're
trying to portray to the public so and
I'd like to acknowledge um Annie and
Jackie Nelson's efforts and mobilizing
this work stream with Plato as well
so thank
you um just to add to that um start of
this year we looked at all the ads that
we're playing currently on radio um in
our channels and we felt that those
advertisements need to be reviewed and
you know to make the message more simple
for the public to relate to with so
that's what we had done um Jackie and
and I had um engaged with the radio
partners and revised the scripts to make
it more pleasing to the public bit has
not bits is not yet out on the radio
channels but you can hear them
soon there'll be some exciting
ads any other comments
feedback so we've got a a um uh
recommendation there that the waste
Advisory Group receives the report
um Christine would you like to add to
that that we receive an update at our
next
meeting you to add that yes and so
you'll move that then so that uh we note
the report and and request that we
receive an update at the next meeting we
have a second for that Barry thank you
um any other
discussion no I'll put the motion all
those in favor say
I against carried so to the team from
Plato creative thank you for for joining
us uh exciting times ahead in that front
and keep up the good work thank you
thank you so much thank
you so we'll reduce back to the uh one
screen thank you uh so we'll move on to
item four which is on page 13 um which
is um waste net waste to lill
Performance
update um which sets out really the
trends that that have occurred um is
there any discussion from um those um
present or questions for the staff
please I think the key thing that's
there is that um the amount of waste
being discarded and the amount of um uh
recycling taking place are both least
this year than
previous um pick picking up on the
discussion just just a couple of moments
ago um I'd be interested to know whether
there is a corresponding Trend in the
opposite direction and illegal
dumping um is it's the waste going down
because less has been generated or less
has been put into the system um I don't
know if staff are able to provide any
comment um I not an educated comment at
this stage in terms of we we haven't
done any analysis around that um what
I'd suspect though is as much as I guess
you have the visual I saw of waste
that's dumped on the roadside I'd
suspect that it's significantly less
tonnage wise um than what we would see
in terms of that drop in waste to
landfill um but it's something that we
can have a look at um what those volumes
are that are coming through that we're
having to go out to collect for illegal
dumping um versus that drop and bring
that back yeah I think I think it's a
useful barometer that um is worthwhile
keeping an eye on um any any other
feedback um in terms of that report
please rob yeah just trying to get my H
around that recycling one with that 25
ton less to almost to your question
where's it actually going if it's not
going because it's not going to landfall
but it's not going to restart things so
people yeah not not a question that can
probably be answered but just trying to
get my he around the cause of that um
drop I think it's one that we're seeing
um a not dissimilar drop across waste
and recycling which may simply be that
it's a time where people are consuming
less at the moment and therefore
discarding less um we've only got a very
short Trend there at the moment it's one
that we'll want to keep an eye on what
the trend
does it's interesting looking at Pages
16 and 17 of the the agenda when you
look at the total total curbside waste
um icc's at the 859 Southern districts
at about a third of that and and um Gore
a little bit more than a quarter um when
I go to the other side of the page and
look at the recycling um uh statistics
and under plastic um South districts are
about 2/3 of
IC and and further down um in terms of
glass um Southland is is about
60% um so Southland seems to be more
energetic or or or more um responsive in
in the recycling when you compare the
figures is the am I reading uh too much
into
that so um when we look at the recycling
figures um when
we when we are looking at the recycling
figures what's happening is the
Southland loads and the um imaga loads
they're not being um sorted separately
um at the recycle South muff MF um you
know on the line so what what I've done
is taken the bin weight proportionate
weight and because it's not um
separately processed I have to apply
that proportionate bin weight to the
entire load which is Southland plus SDC
so this may not be an ideal
representation but yeah proportion
okay um okay um so uh we've got a
recommendation on page
13 um that we receive the report know
note the waste to lold data and Trends
and note the recycling data and Trends
can I have a a mover for the
recommendations please rob moving and
second Christine thank you all those in
favor say I against carried now I'm just
getting a a um message beside me and
um just one moment please
sorry
yeah all right so we go to item five
which is on page
18 um which is the waset education and
communication
update um any feedback and comments from
Members
please Christine um just a comment in
relation to to the previous presentation
and then how um what Plato have um put
forward to us might be included on this
education program for schools and I
imagine you've already thought of that
um and it might be next year before we
see that but I see that
is potential to really engage um the
children and as I'm thinking about I'm
thinking it could be a useful concept on
on um out in our community on posters as
well particularly we were find some of
that
l or use of L on the side of
the and and I see that several of the
staff are nodding their heads and
agreement any any other comment and
feedbacks I see that Eniro schools is is
funded from the three councils and
there's no funding from Wast net going
forward should we be rethinking
that
yeah I think there's nodding all around
the table and um
um the only piece I'd just um remind
everybody to take into consideration on
enir schools is that inviro schools
isn't solely about teaching about waste
um and as I understand it through the
discussions that we've had with with
inviro Schools they're not yet at the
point where they have an actual waste
specific area they also teach a lot
about obviously you know what you put
down your drains not polluting your
waterways things like that as well um so
it's just a question of where is the
most appropriate place to to fund for
that
work thank you for that
feedback in terms of the um
Communications does ICC and and
Southland use an tenno at all Gore and
environment South do um and it's a very
useful tool so Rob you do use it yeah we
do
okay is there any other um feedback
required people want to
make so we have a recommendation that
the waste Advisory Group receives the
report waste net education and
communication update can I have a mover
for that please Barry the
second uh Rob all those in favor I I
Against
carried moving on to item six which is
on page
22 which is the waste net uh waste um
activity Plan
update um from the staff is there
anything in particular you want to draw
our attention to in that no so is there
any feedback and
comment I guess first up uh under the um
box for the separate class collection
investigation uh there's a bullet point
there joint consultation is proposed by
strategy policy and
engagement uh can you please explain
what that
is referring to the IC team that will
lead the strategy on behalf of the three
Council the consultation process on
behalf of the three
councils
we can update that next time to note IC
strategy policy and engagement team okay
um has G gone through the
consultation no no no um we um logic
suggests that uh greatest benefit in
terms of messaging is if we follow um or
at the same time is what ICC goes
through um TimeWise there's nothing to
be gained by jumping out early
um we just like getting on with things
occasionally and yeah but that's logic
um right any any other feedback in terms
of that report there's a fair bit
sitting in there when you look through
each of those items um and we'll wait
for the reports to come through so uh
there is
um there's no recommend ation in the
report but the recommendation would be
that the report um be received can I
have a mve for that please Barry second
um me this time around all those in
favor say I against carried just one
point Mr chairman just as a suggestion I
think my endorsing comments of uh other
committee members about the
comprehensive nature of this these
action plans it did do me when I read it
I thought I wonder how how many just
rank and file counselors that are not
associated with with Wast would know
what the work program is it might
actually be uh a good idea for each
respective Council to put this up to a
committee of their counselor so let Le
the members know what's going on on the
ground there L stuff here thank
you
yes it's um I absolutely Ely agree with
that and I guess I I'd have a question
then
for um the elected members of this
committee we've kind of been tussling
with the idea of should you know the
minutes go through to the respective
councils but it's pretty difficult to
discern anything meaningful out of the
minutes and we did wonder whether or not
at a staff level we should be suggesting
that the full package of papers goes an
as an attachment to each Council but
then that's a lot of content I guess
we'd be really happy to hear any
feedback from elected members on how you
think we might best do that right yeah
we've had a similar kind of conversation
around the joint shareholders committee
for Great South and actually getting
rather than people having to read
through all the minutes in the meeting
but actually doing a summary from each
meeting of the key kind of points
because you can't really glean that from
reading the minutes but just a key
things that we want to point out from
the committee and I think that would
probably be quite useful just almost a
one pager or even a half pager but just
some some key key points and and you're
thinking that should be included in the
council agendas yeah and then that can
be circulated around all all the council
keeps everyone in the
leag I think Mr chairman you know we've
come from a a background where there's
been a little bit of Hit and Miss in
terms of frequency of meetings and a lot
of el members probably feel a little bit
out of the loop and this is a great way
to get back in the loop and back on
S all right moving on to item seven then
on page 25 which is the curbside
recycling bin uh
inspection um and um it it's um fairly
straightforward um and exciting
initiative good good to see that it's
proceeding um so is there any feedback
or comments that people wish to
make Christine thank you I just wasn't
sure if that was starting today or later
in the month it to be two different
comments on
the to answer that question uh we were
planning to do it last week um from just
after the school holidays but
unfortunately the weather hasn't been
that good so this week we are seeing
some promising days probably tomorrow
day after so we might just see how it
goes and then once we start off we need
to keep going for like 2 weeks so just
want to get that 14 days when it's good
weather and we are able to dig that off
thank you thank you it will be
interesting data to receive
back the question I had was that in
looking at the process for inspection if
it's found to be contaminated will the
bin be emptied aan can you
help so I'm happy for the team to jump
into to me here cuz we had quite a bit
of debate around that one um what we
want to make sure that we do is not do
anything too drastically different from
what we have at the moment in
particularly do anything that's not
supported um by bylaw um so at this
stage what would happen is if a bin is
found to be contaminated it would be
sticker um advising people that it's
been contaminated there would also be
some additional educational material
provided to them and Annie as I
understand it when it's stickers
it's not collected that week but will be
collected the following week so
essentially you get a bit of a
inconvenience of not having being
collected that
week thank
you any other feedback or comment bar
that happens um like we get air bins
every second week so if there is one
that's contaminated is the truck
especially going to go back to empty
that
bin
no it'll be just collected as part of
the next routine fortnightly
collection ra sorry mr's questions
probably not too relevant to this this
topic but just around the um seems to be
ironic that every time we have a
recycling day the wind picks up and a
lot of the bins actually blow over which
I think actually contributes to a lot of
the roadside rubbish are we actually
keeping track of the amount of rubbish
that's actually spilling out of the bins
in relation to the wind and I know years
ago I talked about having those tags
over the top to keep the lids shut and
whether that's still being progressed
cuz I think that's sort of a bigger
issue than we might realize as well I I
don't know I suspect throughout entire
Southland that we've had one of the
windiest springs for for many years um
and it may not be a true reflection of
what happens on on a normal year but um
I think your your point is well made
eron do you want to provide any feedback
on
that um so the bin tags is an
interesting one and it's just been tied
up a little bit with the the transfer of
bond Contracting um generally the
contractors don't like the bin tags
because they feel that it stops the bin
opening and then they have to get out
and adjust the bin um be honest in my
experience of having introduced them in
central ataro the contractors weren't
very comfortable with them and then once
they were put on um they got used to
them pretty quickly um so now that there
is obviously New Management in place
with wasteco we'll pick up that
conversation with them um I guess part
of the question that I put to elected
members is there's a couple of ways we
could go about the bin tags one is that
we could fund them as part of
essentially you know roll out of an
initiative where we actually pay for
them um I forget the exact amounts but I
think they were about $7 roughly a tag
last time we looked at them um or the
other option is that we can simply have
them available for purchase at the front
counters of of each of the councils and
and just provider an education plug for
them thank you any other feedback
comments so we have a recommendation
that the um waste Advisory Group
receives the
report oh sorry Christine thank you I
just Endor looking further at the um
tags and also this funding within was
for that to be to be done um today I put
my been out being a Monday for the first
time for six weeks because of the wind
issue and as I drove out of winon a
fortnight ago I think it was every bin
on the main road was lying on its side
and it was just rubbish going everywhere
so and the wind we've experienced for
the last month or well six weeks at
least obviously then I think we need to
be proactive about stopping the
littering that's happening um as a
result of the wind events that were well
I guess um the the weight of what's in
the recycling bins is substantially less
and and makes them easier to blow over
and um if they're blowing over then the
contractors need to hop out of their
vehicle in order to to stand them up to
get them into the the truck um so um
yeah it's something that needs to be
booked it I guess moving forward
yes so we had received a few R offices
uh from members of the public um that
their bins have been um tipped over and
um being rubbish being blown everywhere
so I had been in touch with wsco and um
theyve requested their drivers to hop
out of the truck um clear up the
surrounding areas but obviously they're
not chasing the rubbish that's been
blown out so that's they're doing a good
job there right thank you yeah yeah so
they're using a a good practice as
practical
um right any the other feedback
just yeah as see the B tags are about $7
something another each I think uh I
think we should be probably funding that
because during those Hard Times everyone
$7 is
$7 is an issue that we need to resolve
so well I think is next year's um
Financial um planning uh something worth
having a talk
about
y so I think um just to put it in
context doing some very quick rough
numbers um we've got just under 40,000
as I understand it eligible properties
um across the region um and a you would
require a bin tag for each of once we
move to a three bin system each of the
three bins um so you're talking over
$100,000 um to fund those which is
obviously doable but it will be a decent
chunk of money hence my comment to have
a talk about yes Christine thank you I
just wondered if recycling was a place
to start because the bins are a lot
lighter yeah and whereas with the red
bins I don't see the same issue
happening you know we can have a report
at some stage back yeah we we we can we
can bring a report with some different
options for it I think the other thing
too is if you send it out to everybody
people may not use them um what I found
is if you buy you know 10,000 of them
and have them in the various different
offices those people who want them will
come and collect them but you're not
going to get in everybody doing a takeup
yeah good point
so the recommendation we've have is the
waste Advisory Group receives the report
um waste net curbside recycling bin
inspection can I have a move for that
please Barry and second uh from Rob all
those in favor say I against
carried item eight on page 27 waste
minimization a management and
minimization plan implementation report
um um there is a great summary that goes
with that as part of the background and
one that I'll I'll keep in use as an
explanation um is there any feedback or
comment that uh people wish to
make on page 28 there's um reference to
the um Eniro schools hoie being held in
November um and I'm just wondering to
the staff whether this governance group
should have a presence at
that and I'm picking up on your comment
that waste is a small part of what Eniro
schools does but is is there some
benefit in actually having uh a present
and giving a little bit of
profile
just just three s Mr chair um the
presentation that was tabled through
environment Southland regarding the
initiative and the upcoming h um they
were widely quite vocal um as in
councilors and elected officials
attending the hill effort all possible
so yeah we would um endorse that Rec
recommendation as well yeah so Barry
just highlighted that he's received an
invite um I don't recall receiving
anything in Gore so staff can follow up
on that please um Christine umg I
haven't received an invite but I have
been before it was really worthwhile
just long you don't have to stay for the
whole day
but so is it your intention to go along
bar yeah good
good the on page 29 uh there's reference
to the kpi and data reporting on three
bullet points um highlighting ICC
internal measures for kpis ltp measures
and waste net measures um eron can you
just expand on that a little bit please
um what what what's the
message I can take that one thank you um
so I had gone through the kpis and um
put them into three categories just for
better observing the trend so put some
for internal um just for us to um see
how we are doing um when it comes to
recycling diversion and um waste that's
been discarded to landf then we had a
set of kpis that we regularly reported
in the ltp um but the internal measures
are sort of like per capita on those um
ltp measures it's just for better
understanding how waste is performing
now and
um compared to when uh the the previous
years and the waste net measures are
again those kpis that both for ICC is
being calculated for go and SDC and ICC
together now and being reported out as
um waste net kpis to wmg and um to wag
as
well so you've looked at the in tuna
ones for IC should the other councils be
doing the same I think that that's the
piece that we just haven't explained to
here very well what we've done initially
is work with the IC team because they're
here around that balance between inter
measures and H of regional measures and
then sharing that information with the
other two councils around where we've
gotten to and where they'd like to
potentially take up around internal
measures um versus just having a h of
place net measure right thank
you the item um paragraph below that
talks about the community Grant um
scheme that that opened on the 18th of
September and closes in in 3 weeks um
has there been much response to that to
date sorry Keith could you just repeat
the question please chair yeah so the um
applications for um the community grant
funding um are open at present it's
about halfway through so has there been
much response um sry I didn't hear that
question ini really sorry about that um
we have just one application at this
stage
right any other uh feedback
from those
present I'm just getting a little
concerned in terms of the key curbside
standardization it comes into force on
the 1 of February which is four months
away and we lose a month and a bit over
the Christmas period um material from MF
has yet to arrive um so just I guess to
note that
um I think how do I say this
respectfully I don't think we ever um
put all of our cookies in getting all of
the information that we would require
from MF and we always had a bit of a
plan of intending that we would have to
at least very much supplement that
information if not provide the
information ourselves um so that's well
progressed at the I guess at the waste
net level around what we need to do um
regardless of what we get from um MF
right Pages 31 and 32 is a comprehensive
table of of the action tracker are there
any um feedback or questions that people
have Barry yeah on page 30 uh B disposal
project project it mentions M
and staff had a good a word with them
about these lithium
batteries just three your s chair the
there's two streams we we're looking at
addressing in the battery waste disposal
project so the first stream is around
domestic batteries which which is
obviously tabled through Ma's National
initiative and the second stream is
around bulk B e waste batteries
so we weren't able to report on that
because we're waiting on a key action
from a national supplier as they're
implementing a national Nationwide
program in that space so we opted to
hold until we reported to wag around
that but uh from an you're talking from
a combustion perspective of of the
battery the way that these batteries are
actually stored and what they're stored
in I believe have been known to take
impact so yes they would combust if they
were to combust they would combust
however it would be a contained
combustion and an isolated location of
how they
stalled Christine thank you I think
there's a report to come back to us in
December isn't it in Rel to the battery
so we can expect to see some clear
information at that time and there was
also something that when visited AB line
they talked about the risk and we
already had an incident just recently
where one of the vehicles drrive over
the batter so they expressed the great
concern around this
is Wast net have been up with AB lime in
the last three weeks onto landfill and
we've met with the health and safety
team there have been seven instances
this year alone around e batteries so um
yeah we are aware of the significance of
this and we're working as diligently as
possible so in in part it links through
to what's described as item 2.4 at the
bottom of page 31 that's um in terms of
advocacy to central government and when
we have our by the time we have our next
meeting I expect that we will have um
ministers appointed to their um
appropriate
portfolios um under the new government
and I'd like to have a discussion at
that point in terms of matters that we
should be advocating to government um to
take um some more urgent action than
than others and highlight issues that we
have down here and I think the the whole
battery um issue um together with some
of the organic um uh approach that's
been in place in the p and um its
appropriateness in the regional Landfill
are matters that we should be looking at
advocating Peter yeah just getting back
to the uh the batteries we when they
disposed the ab l site are they disposed
in a separate area or they with all
other
rubbish currently it's comingled so that
goes on with General waste so it's hard
to split them out if you like just given
how they discarded the read bin yeah
thank
you attached to this report starting at
page 35 is the public place an event
recycling um
guideline um um if there's any feedback
that comments that people want to make
in relation to
that I guess the note that I um made on
on page
39 um is of the agenda was really in
relationship that where there are large
scale events in most cases they require
consent from count councils um be it for
uh land use consent or health um
consents Etc um so implementation of of
this initiative which is a great one um
is is really for the councils to
implement and follow through um so I
just just note
that um one one thing I think that the
um that discussion document is um a
little light on
um or guidelin is a little light on is
event signage not only on the day but
leading up to it so where there are
major events you tend to see signs all
over the place beforehand and I think
that the guidelines um capturing them as
well um would be
useful um just just to highlight
um we're practical to use um signage
that's capable of use on more than one
uh occasion um or with materials that
are more environmentally sensitive than
others um so I guess a move away from
some of the plastic signs that we've had
in the past to something that that is
capable of being recycled that's more an
observation than anything else is there
any other feedback or comments in terms
of um the
report just regarding a large event uh
like rugby park and and race courses
around the region um there's virtually
no recycling down those venues at all
everything goes into the same bin I know
rugby park is's about 58 bins and
everything goes into those bins so we're
not sort of promoting it too well uh
around the region even at race courses
it's the same at race courses yeah
although I I take this as the this
report is the beginning of a more uh
engaging um approach to encourage it to
be adopted happy to speak to that um
you'll have seen from and apologies
Peter you won't have seen this but for
the other elected members there's an
action plan that talks about the waste
net priorities based on um obviously the
staff capability and the various
different tasks that we have to do this
year was very much focused around
education in schools and that that radio
and media advertising the business plan
then has a next step of moving into how
we promote uh waste minimization with
businesses and that would very much pick
up those sorts of um community- based
events as well because absolutely most
businesses around the place as well as
most event holders aren't getting into
that diversion space yet
thanks on page 62 appendix 8 um it's a a
report really from in 2012 and it
surprised me that in the results at the
bottom there were X's or unknown uh
quantities for the materials recovered
and and percentage wise um I doubt
you're in a position to actually um
provide any figures from
those so that's um you know under
results on page 62 of the agenda 28 of
the um
guidelines um I'll need to come back to
you on that one I need to look up the
figures and come back to you all right
any other feedback
then
Christine you just in relation to this
this document when was it last
updated this was last updated last year
last year yeah so it's it's although the
examples are quite old within the I
guess the feedback showing that the what
is in here is pretty effective um it's
just um a starting point we need to
revise this and uh align it with great
outs um event policies as well and then
uh bring out a um an updated document
that would be good thank you and I
always find it helpful to have examples
completed examples in the documents for
those who are going to use it it's yeah
good good information to about how to do
and things may not app thank
you thank you uh any other
comment right we have a recommendation
that the waste Advisory Group receed the
report can I have a mover for that
please Barry and the
second I'll do
that um all those in favor say I I
against carried that brings us to the
end of the public uh session I'd like to
move that we now move into public
excluded yes Erin before we do just
before we move out of the public session
and unfortunately she's not sitting down
the back anymore but I did just want to
thank Jackie Nelson who's done a
significant amount of work on that um
Community engagement piece um Jackie
will be moving on from waset and IC
ahead of the next meeting and um we're
currently in the process of recruiting
for her replacement but just wanted to
say thank you to her for the great work
that she's done totally agree thank you
I think that whole initiative and the
work that's gone into it is excellent so
I'd like to move that the public be
excluded from the following parts of the
proceedings and it's consideration of
the minutes of the public excluded
portion of the waste Advisory Group
meeting of the 11th of September and the
reason for doing so is that um uh
necessary to protect information of
commercial sensitivity as set out on
page three of the agenda can I have a a
second for that please um Barry thank
you all those in
favor against
carried